voilà un gouvernement qui fait comme si
il n'avait pas été là pendant cinq ans
qui reconnaît que pendant 5 avec une
majorité absolue il n'a rien réussi à
faire et qui nous annonce qu'il va donc
tout pouvoir tout faire sans majorité et
il ya une espèce d'appel oui
officiellement la responsabilité
en réalité c'est un sauve-qui-peut n'est
pas ça qu'on a au nom du gouvernement de
lui dire voilà nous avons fait des
erreurs il ya eu des blocages il ya eu
des choses qui ne sont pas fait et c'est
pour ça que nous avons perdu les
élections et à partir de là très bien la
main à une majorité relative qui avec
nous peu avancé sur trois quatre
priorités voilà c'est ce qu'on attend
d'elle ce qu'on n'aurait pu discuter à
la prévert où tout y passe sans moindre
équilibre sans la moindre priorité sans
dire combien tout cela coûte parce que
si on fait le bilan de tout ce qui était
dit las d'après midi ces centaines de
milliards ils sont ces centaines de
milliards franchement quand vous avez
échoué le premier élément c'est de dire
aux gens ce en face de vous
on vous a pas traités comme il fait
on aurait dû être plus attentifs aux
demandes du parlement nous le saurons
davantage
et voilà comment nous allons faire et
voilà sur quelles priorités
éventuellement que travailler ensemble
pouvoir d'achat sécurité immigration est
ce que vous êtes prêts à travailler avec
nous là dessus on ne met pas les mesures
prêts décidés sur la table ont dit on va
on se voit on discute on sort des
mesures et ensemble on les appelait ça
sa hotte et du dialogue mais venir le
dire à la voilà vous annonce tout ce
qu'on veut et puis vous êtes priés
d'être responsables de venir avec nous
donc ce gouvernement
pardon de le dire a peu de chance de
durer où est le changement pourrait
changements sur la méthode de fou nulle
part et c'est bien ça inquiétant et
reviennent pour nous dire on va
continuer mais on va habiller
on n'est pas là pour fournir les
vêtements
[Musique]